welcome to philanthropy in action I am
Maxum thorne and I teach philanthropy in
action here
University I'm delighted today to have
as our guest Donna Dubinsky Donna has
had a most remarkable career in the
field of Technology she's a first in so
many areas Donna thank you for coming my
pleasure Donna I was so looking forward
to this conversation because it is so
rare to have one a breakthrough artist
in the field of technology who has your
particular background and who has
decided to also become engaged
philanthropically what motivated you to
bring these two aspects of your life
together well I think it comes upon you
gradually I was not born into a wealthy
family I mean a solid middle-class
environment to be sure but not great
wealth but my parents were always very
generous and giving of their time and
their money and so I was I was raised in
an environment where it was important to
give back but you don't I don't think
you really understand the implications
of having great wealth until you know
you get kind of close to that point
yourself and as I did start to get into
that position myself over the years it
became clear more clear to me that I had
to start thinking about what the
implications were of that and I think
the number one implication for me was as
I thought about it that I had been able
to take advantage of so many things that
society had provided for me whether my
public school growing up or my parents
paying for my college or Yale and all of
it had to offer and that it was really
my responsibility now to do that for the
next generation and and I had to start
to kind of think about that and think
about how to go about that which is it's
not an easy thing to think about and how
you do that thoughtfully and responsibly
and with the most amount of impact and I
think I got I got kind of turned off of
the idea of inherited well I think both
from a perspective of society as well as
from the perspective of an individual
from a society perspective it just seems
to me it doesn't generate as much
creativity and in
evasion and from an individual
perspective I think it's almost
demotivational somebody doesn't really
have to work hard for for what they're
getting so you know I for ourselves in
my family my husband and I we sort of
said okay we're going to take care of
our family we're going to make sure
nobody's out the cold or struggling or
they're safe they're safe but after that
I think the rest of what we've been able
to earn based on the privileges we've
had in our society we think we should be
giving back tell us a little bit about
the trajectory you have had so that so
that we get a sense of of how you moved
from a solidly middle-class background
through being the CEO of palm and and
getting and growing your wealth base how
did that happen and and is there a
connection to you being an entrepreneur
to your views about inherited wealth
well sure there's there's definitely a
connection there I mean I my me my story
is i went i came to Yale I had never
really been exposed to education like
this I went to a very poor public high
school where I did not get a good
education so it was that in Benton
Harbor Michigan and I came here totally
unprepared for the academic rigor of
Yale not like you guys today where you
get so much great prep to come here I I
was really it was a struggle for me in
my first couple years here to figure out
how to study and how to write papers and
all those kind of things but I just
thrived in it I just loved it I loved
this place I loved everything I could
learn from it and then I went out into
the working world for a couple years I
went to a bank in Philadelphia as a
trainee and loved the business world and
decided that's where I wanted to focus I
went back to business school at Harvard
and got my MBA and I wasn't really sure
what I wanted to do I had been in the
bank and I'd seen entrepreneurs and
shin and I got kind of excited then
about entrepreneurship it was a mainly
cable TV systems it was you probably
can't relate to this but in the very
very beginning of cable TV when they
were just installing it it was a very
entrepreneurial venture small guys doing
it town by town by town and I was
financing them so I got to know them and
really appreciate them and I decided
that I was really interested in in
entrepreneurial activities and then
Apple computer came to campus to recruit
the first time they ever came to harvard
business school they were interviewing
for technical people I was not a
technical person so they didn't accept
me for an interview but I went and sat
outside the interview room all day and
every time the interviewer came out and
said you know how you have to
reintroduce myself to her and say I'm
here to see you and she said well you're
not at my schedule and I'd say I know
but I need to talk to you because I
really need to come work for Apple so by
the end of the day she agreed to sit
down and talk to me and I ended up being
the only person who was hired from the
Harvard Business School to go to apple
so it was kind of interesting and I
ended up in a logistics role in
operations where I won't go through all
the details because it goes on and on
but I just I loved the fast pace i love
the innovation i loved it was a crazy
time at apple i mean just hyper growth
and i got responsibilities very quickly
and just really got a taste for on the
entrepreneurial and innovative and
product innovation all those things so i
wanted to stick with that when I left
Apple I took a year off and and decided
that I really wanted to try to run
something I felt like I had the skills
to be a CEO I wanted to try to be a CEO
and I came back specifically looking for
a CEO opportunity in a very small
start-up and that's when I met my
business partner Jeff who I'm now on my
third company with and as co-founder pom
and then you know back to kind of circle
back to the wealth question you know
joining a start-up and getting a a piece
of it is certainly how you have an
opportunity to build wealth so now I was
hired at palm as the CEO so I got kind
of a percentage as a CEO and then in our
second company I was a co-founder so I
had a significantly higher percentage of
the second company as
co-founder and then ironically enough we
sold the second company back to the
first company and I ended up with more
of palm the second time around that I
had the first time around which I always
loved but yeah that's that's how it
happened and then you know the company
went public and did well and so I did
well and that's a story so I I'm not
sure where well I know the students have
exactly questions that are related to
what you just said okay because one of
the challenges from the philanthropic
movement point of view is how do you
replicate the what has been so
successful in in in the business world
and in this new field of social
entrepreneurship and and venture capital
and all the things that have made people
involved in technology so successful
innovation cereal and you know those
kinds of things and how are those
lessons that could add value to the
philanthropic world but so Dan sure well
I have a related question so the
technologies that you've developed
throughout your career have changed the
lives of millions of people for the
better hopefully and all and so I think
it would be you know probably possibly
easy for you to just sort of say well
that's my contribution you've also
chosen to give philanthropic Lee in a
variety of ways as well and I guess I'm
just wondering do you feel it was that a
choice of yours do you think that's sort
of an obligation that you know binds
someone else as well like is can your
career be the sole extent of your Flint
appeared as a goatee deeper than that
well I guess um I think your career is
an important part of your giving back I
think not just making devices that
change people's lives and make their
worlds better but also building an
ethical responsible company that
contributes to a community that's that's
taking care of its suppliers and its
employees and everybody in the whole
ecosystem I mean I really see a company
as as an ethical entity too and that it
needs to be able to balance the needs of
multiple constituencies I mean you might
want to raise prices but that might you
know in
pack your investors positively but your
customers negatively so these are always
a balancing act of how do you manage
these things together and I think
thinking that through and understanding
I mean your ecosystem touches so many
people I mean I had however many
thousand employees we had in the company
but we were touching the lives of vast
multiples of that all the way down
through the supply chain anybody in
China who made the display who then
shipped it through a trucking company
and then so on and so forth so so I
think that needs to be an ethical system
and you need to think about that from
that perspective but in addition to that
so then you have this money that you
make as a result which I think for some
people it's a scorecard and they want to
hang on to it because they don't they
think they're losing score they're
losing points if they give it away but
for me it's really a way to make an
impact in other ways and for me it's
just a treasure to be able to use it in
that way I mean I spend it on myself to
I have things I enjoy but but I really
love to have the opportunity to make a
difference in the world in other ways in
addition to the ways that I've made a
difference in the company don't know on
on that bill bill gates posited this
idea of creative capitalism in which he
broadened the the notion that the one
can have an ethical company and a
company can i play a broader role than
just profit maximization for
shareholders and in that way we can
actually see multiple returns to society
beyond you know the the great product
that a company makes or for the
shareholder money that they will give as
a residual because that's their money to
give but the company itself can be
ethical and have an impact but a lot of
people oppose that view and say no
companies should be limited to profit
maximization sort of in the freedmen
sense do you agree with that I think
profit maximization is really a too
narrow of a definition of the role of
the company I might say I'm more on Bill
Gates aside on this that you know
company is is a member of the community
in some sense and needs to play a role
in the broad broadly defined community
and you know you have to be careful
about it because certainly you have to
pay attention to profits and investors
is one very key element of that
community because if you don't pay
attention to them they're not going to
keep financing your company and you're
not going to have a company and all your
wonderful things for employees are going
to go away so I think you know it's a
balancing act it's all about being
balanced but I think that part of that
balance is are those other
constituencies so I don't understand the
notion of taking one constituency
investors and putting them way above all
of those other constituencies to me that
that's not does it make sense
intellectually but it also doesn't make
sense for the long-term health of the
company i think the long-term health of
a company will be far better if the
company is trying to balance all those
constituencies having a great place for
employees to work for example you can
say investors would be better served if
you try to pay people the lowest
possible amount but i think in the end
investors are better served if the
employees are happy and thriving and
building careers and enjoying themselves
and being creative and innovative so you
know it all plays together it's very
complex Linda hi so I know that people
often say you either win or lose but you
know I sometimes thank you either win or
learn so i was wondering as an
entrepreneur as a serial entrepreneur
can you give us an example of when you
have failed and learned from such
failures oh I failed so often I don't
know where to start them well you know
our early years at Palm were very very
difficult we created our first product
was a failure we did a product with
Cassio where we did the software and
they did the hardware and it was one of
the very earliest handhelds was called
the Zoomer I wish I brought it with me
it's like this big and very ugly by
today's standards but it was a really a
breakthrough product at the time but it
wasn't very good and it didn't do a lot
and it was expensive and so it was a
total failure and
we had to figure out how to move forward
as a company after that and we'd learned
an awful lot we learned a lot about what
customers did want and what they didn't
want and how much they would pay it how
much they wouldn't pay and all these
things and that's what the palm pilot
was born out of was all of that learning
and we unfortunately were not able to
finance that vision I mean we had a very
clear vision we had a very clear product
plan we were marching down that and
nobody was interested in financing so I
was unsuccessful and raising money to
finance that product which ultimately
became a multi-billion dollar business
so we ended up selling the company in
order to finance the product to another
company so that's kind of you know I
mean it's all been an incredible series
of ups and downs and ups and downs and
it's taken just huge you know
persistence and tenacity to actually
take those learnings and turn them into
something I mean when we sold the
company many people called and they said
congratulations what are you going to do
next and it was like no no we sold the
company in order to finance it and bring
this product to market I'm staying right
here and finishing what I've started it
wasn't the idea of au turn something and
make some money and go on and do
something else we believe that this
product could make a big difference in
people's lives and we wanted to get this
product on the market and selling the
company was the means to the end not the
end so so that's what we did but you
know and and I mean I could give you a
million other examples I mean it's been
a whole career in effect of mistakes and
learning and adjustment and mistakes and
learning and adjustment and just a
constant stream of reacting to what
you're learning from the environment
Linda is was their reason that you asked
that question well I've been attending a
lot of conferences recently and I'm a
part of the social enterprise called
Isaac and we have been we just started
at Yale maybe three years ago and we've
been trying new ways to get people
excited about Isaac trying new ways to
get more of our product out there which
is international exchange and a lot of
these conferences are revolve around
ideas exchange people coming together
talk
about how they failed how they want how
they understood how we can move on and I
sec so i was just wondering yeah well
it's an iterative process you know you
do the best you can at your first shot
whether you know it's a group and what
the Charter is or a product whatever and
and then you listen and you've got to be
a good listener listen to that your
customers your suppliers your employees
everybody around you is thinking about
this and then keep making adjustments we
just did that in my current company just
this week we made an adjustment in our
strategy based on what we're hearing
from our beta customers so if you if you
stick rigidly to your first thought
there and don't learn from what's going
on then I think for sure you're going to
fail for sure Donna listening to you I
think there's a special intelligence a
different intelligence that comes from
people from Silicon Valley people who
are involved in technology because one
of the things that you have said to
rephrase it is that you you embrace
failure because to come up with
something new it's okay to fail and to
learn from that in a lot of different
trophic world that is anathema it's as
if everything you invest in is supposed
to be successful and the idea that one
could be innovative or come up with
multiple strategies is seen as risky or
not the best use of the donors funds but
it seems that people with your
background tend to embrace a different
view so that you can come up with some
different solutions that have been tried
do you agree with that statement well I
think you embrace failure it's okay to
fail but you don't want to do it too
many times I mean there's a limit and I
think that as long as if you're a
philanthropic organization as long as
you position something as experimental
here we're going to give this a try
here's what we hope to learn from it
here's how we're going to react to what
we learn from it here's what we're
trying to learn whatever then I think
it's perfectly fine to go into that eyes
wide open and say this may work this may
not work I think the mistake is
if you say oh we're sure this is going
to work this is you know absolutely the
right thing to do and we're all set and
boom and then it doesn't work then
you've really reduced your credibility a
lot so it's it's an awful lot about
positioning upfront about humility about
understanding really deeply what you
know and what you don't know i mean you
know right now we have an incredible
technology that we're working on we know
for sure that this is break your
technology this is important stuff we
don't really know how it intersects yet
with user needs so we're working on that
and we know we don't know that so that's
why we're sort of making course
corrections now but being able to
articulate and understand what you know
and what you don't know and being
totally brutally honest with that to
yourself to your teammates to your
investors your funders is I think
incredibly important thank you leepy hi
I was wondering in this in this book we
read by David bornstein in how to change
the world he emphasizes the role of the
social entrepreneur essentially a
philanthropist who approaches social
problems in the same way she might
approach business problems and I was
hoping to gain your perspective on what
you might think about that process and
also how you might approach social
issues you know I've been a little more
in the skeptical camp on the whole
social entrepreneurship notion partly
because what I've seen is is running a
non-profit and doing things for a
non-profit is fundamentally different
than running it for profit and you know
in spite of what I said earlier about
you know balancing constituents
constituencies I believe that for profit
has to be a for-profit I mean quite
seriously otherwise it's not going to
survive and endure over the long run and
grow and thrive and a not-for-profit is
a very different thing and and I feel
there's been a little bit of hubris in
my community of saying oh we know better
how to run these nonprofits because
we've run these other companies so well
and some of the things translate and
some of the things don't translate and
are a very different environment and I
feel like there are some
really stunning philanthropies out there
who do a wonderful job of creating
enormous value enormous products
services for people who need it and we
shouldn't be dismissive of them as
saying oh they're not social
entrepreneurs I think we should learn
from them because I think they know a
lot about how to do that right so I feel
I feel a little more respectful of that
community that I that I hear when I hear
this sort of social entrepreneurship
notion you know I love the fact that you
talked about the hubris because it has
been especially in the last say the bill
anthropol moment the Bill Gates moment
in which a lot of people who are
brilliant and have a particular kind of
talent believe that that talent is
directly translatable to the the world
of you know poverty alleviation or
getting rid of major diseases or fixing
education but but you wonder what the
what that is built on because they've
been people working on these of these
issues for ya a long time yeah and I
think they're really different and hard
hard issues in other ways now they
certainly these people such as myself or
the other people do this bring values I
mean the idea of you know of how you
create management systems and how you
have measurement systems and how you you
know create teams I mean there's a whole
bunch of great stuff that that does
carry over but there's other things that
don't I mean the most the most
significant one in my view that I've
learned you know parley being here as a
part of the community at Yale too is
that you know in an NN for-profit
enterprise as the CEO anybody who's not
somebody I want on my team I can fire
and that's one of your most important
tools to managing your organization is
who is there around the table and are
they the right people or not and that's
not always true in the education system
you can't just go in and fire the people
who you don't think or perform
you know you've got restrictions on that
that the society has agreed to place on
that and so you know there are real
hardcore differences that I think people
from my world get in there and just tear
their hair out because they just can't
believe they can't make things happen
the way they're used to making things
happen I'm so glad you know one of our
previous guests was Julian Bond the
great Civil Rights icon and when you
think about social change and equality
for african-americans or for women or
for the LGBT community how do you fire a
movement who in the movement do you fire
and how does a person who is expert in
supplier monopoly or expert delivery
systems you know of medicines which are
great but how are those translatable
when you're dealing with trying to do a
systemic change for social justice yeah
but people claim our problem I know
people think they can do it they can
reinvent everything so but anyway I do
think there are things that are really
wonderful that that community brings in
and there's other things they just have
to learn they have to learn themselves
Steven hi um so some of the largest
problems facing the world's poorest
people today are issues of global health
economic development and political
corruption what role if any do you see
the tech industry playing in addressing
these problems well I'm not sure I think
that certainly there are products that
can make a difference I think generally
speaking access to information that has
grown in the last decade in a way the
world is never before seen has has got
to help that situation because I think
as people in those places get more
educated and informed about what the
rest of the world is like what their
options are how other societies manage I
think they will they will rise up and
they will make a difference in their own
lives I don't think you know the tech
world is going to come in and magically
solve any specific thing but certainly
as we've seen
the Arab Spring last year the role of
Technology was you know really enormous
and we always said at POM you know palm
was always about that personal computing
would be mobile computing that the
future of personal computing was mobile
computing and that your device on you
would be your access to the world and
much more so than your desktop device
your desktop device a couple thousand
dollars with an IT person for every 10
devices with lots of support last thing
you know that just was never going to
fly into the poor parts of the world in
terms of being a reasonable way for
people to get access to the rest of the
world and information in the internet
but these handheld devices could get
cheap enough to do that and we always
said there'll be more accesses to the
internet from a handheld device
particularly the poor parts of the world
then from desktop devices and I believe
that is happening i think the explosion
of software based cell phones with
technology to get on the internet is
democratizing information in a way the
world has never seen before so you know
i think that's probably the biggest
impact you can have as education and
information and then see where people go
with it you know it's just too big of an
issue to take on directly Leslie hey
thank you again for coming my question
is related to risk which of course is an
important part of the business world and
how you manage risk in your philanthropy
so specifically I was wondering whether
you have a preference between investing
in an individual and maybe that
individuals one brilliant idea or in a
more stable investment say a larger
group that's well established I think we
want to invest a lot in leaders and that
leader could be an individual that
leader could be the head of a you know
enormous organization but for my husband
and I we it really is very important
that we believe in the person themselves
who is executing and we're willing to
put our money where we think somebody
can deliver what they're offering to
deliver I mean they're really kind of
its it's like an investment in a
business in some sense because their
people want to invest in the tea
and that's what I want to do I want to
invest in the team I want to believe
it's somebody who can really do what
what they say they could do and so for
us we've invested both in very very
large organizations we've supported and
we've supported some very small
organizations to and we see somebody who
we think is really passionate and really
capable and executing well and a mission
that's consistent with the things that
we're trying to accomplish we'll do that
as well that we wouldn't be restricted
by that at all but if we see an
organization where we don't think the
leadership is very good then we wouldn't
go there the other thing we do which i
think is interesting is we really do due
diligence on people who we you know give
money to so we want to see their books
we want to see that they're profitable
we want to see I'm not profitable that
their break-even that they're not you
know losing money we want to see that
there they've got good governance that
they've got systems in place to review
their CEO that they are thinking about a
board and how they get good board
members on it that you know we like to
see good governance in an organization
to know that it can endure to know that
if it runs into difficulties that it's
going to get through those difficulties
and it's going to go on this though is
potentially problematic because isn't it
okay to have a limited time span because
there are some entities that should in
fact exist but exist for a limited
duration and I'm sure you wouldn't
disagree with that that it's okay if the
lifespan is five years or ten years with
with it with what if they've resolved
the issue that they were set up to be
right yes but that would need to be
deliberate I mean I think the
organization would say to itself okay
here's our mission when when our mission
is accomplished we're going to fold up
shop and go away mind you I think that
never happens I think it should happen
more than it does happen because
organizations have a way of perpetuating
themselves they have a way of saying
okay well let's find something else to
do with what you've done with this thing
but you know let's say hypothetically in
organ is
asian came to terms of that and said
this is our this is what we want to
accomplish and let's get through it and
accomplish it good governance wouldn't
prevent you from from achieving that
good governance would enable you to
achieve that in my view right McLean
well along similar lines I was curious I
as we have expanded new menta and palm I
was curious why you had chosen to why
you have chosen to donate to Yale a huge
organization that receives many monetary
donations every year huge monetary
donations and as here's you know as a
class our selves as a seminar that has a
hundred thousand dollars to work with
what do you advise for us you chose to
donate to a large organization like Yale
versus a smaller organization and you
know searching and looking into various
organizations ourselves we're wondering
why whether we should choose the against
malaria foundation that serves many many
people that have suffer from malaria in
in African countries that support you
know they give a give net send that go
over the beds and saves many lives or
should we look towards more to locally
to the Columbus house that you know
provides a safe haven for people
suffering from homelessness right in our
area and i was wondering kind of what
you suggest for us and and where we
should look and what you know that's a
that's a great question their first of
all i will tell you this there's no bad
cause so if you're looking for the ones
to come in we could say you know what
that's a bad cause we're not going to us
in it just doesn't exist all the causes
are good and you could sit here for the
next 24 hours and tell me great causes
so one does need to choose and my
husband and I kind of confronted this
issue a few years ago and said because
we were just kind of randomly just
picking things that sounded interesting
and you know not really thinking about
it and we decided we had to think about
this and be more deliberate about it and
so we actually came up with a system and
this is what our system looks like I
think you have to think about your own
system but i'll share our system with
you we came up with a matrix and we said
across the top are things that are
important to us so the arts education
addressing poverty
were Jewish so Jewish issues whatever we
had you know the things across the top
and then down the side we had kind of
regional local regional national
international and then we took
everything we were giving all the
dollars and we plotted them in this to
just say well what are we doing let's
start out with a question of where are
we giving money and understand it and
and that process get really opened my
eyes to a few things because I realized
there were some things that we weren't
doing that we should be doing some
things that we were maybe overdoing that
we didn't need to be doing so we've used
that as a framework for ourselves to
figure out which things we we want to do
and we then contest things on that so
when something comes in that's in one of
those areas then we look and see are we
already invested enough in that area or
not okay is this something we should
consider and it gives us it gives us a
framework then we look at other criteria
like I think your question is a really
good one of you know why give money to
Yale when they have so much money
because after all you know it's just a
drop in the bucket I'm not a billionaire
I'm not going to go you know give a
hundred million dollars to build the
next building here I simply can't make
that kind of an impact at Yale so my
impact is going to be far less I gave
money to the last campaign and they I
dedicated it to the new bass library
just because that was such a big deal
for me having spent CCL my hopefully
undergraduate career and so but it was
you know it was enough to just get my
plaque on the wall so everybody calls it
Donna's wall so you can go visit my
plaque on the wall at CCL wasn't a
building so I'm not going to make an
impact at Yale like other people can but
the the you know still I feel it's
important to participate so I choose to
participate at Yale I know as a member
of the corporation that a huge
percentage of the cost of educating a
student here is not paid by tuition even
somebody paying full tuition so one
needs to get that the rest of that from
donations are from the endowment and so
I feel I
tended here on somebody else's money to
a great extent and so I need to provide
that for you guys and the next
generation so I feel sometimes I'm
giving for participation purposes
because I feel like it's an institution
that was important to me that I want to
participate other times I'm giving where
I really feel like our money and the
scale we can give will make a difference
where where we can have a direct impact
on what's going to happen and without us
it wouldn't happen and so those are we
have a mix of those things i would say
thank you donna for coming here this
evening and sharing your wonderful
insights with with our students it is so
important to have the vision Sheard
cross-generational e for all you've
achieved especially as we face such an
equality in the world today and so many
problems that need to be resolved and
hopefully with people like yourself
giving back and sharing your talent your
time and your treasure we can do that
and so I ask you what are you going to
do to change the world